policy objective here is is not to
detain children but it's important that
we don't inadvertently create a policy
that incentivizes people to bring
children who wouldn't otherwise come
here and that's why it's important that
it applies equally to families because
otherwise you increase the likelihood
that people bring children here they
make very dangerous Crossings I don't
think anyone would want to see that
that's not good for children
um so the policy should and must apply
to families but it's right for them we
then look at families differently as we
do and they should be in accommodation
that's appropriate for them and that
those family groups should not be
separated I think that is that is the
right thing to do because otherwise you
know you create it as I said you create
an incentive for a criminal gang to tell
people to bring a child with them when
they otherwise wouldn't be and I don't
think that is a good thing I don't think
we want to create a pull factor to make
it more likely that children are being
making this very perilous journey in
conditions that are appalling I don't
think that's the right thing to do we
should not create a system that makes
that more likely